c'est un mastodonte ce n'est rien
construit en chine fait 219 mètres de
long s'élève sur 12 niveaux et
transporte 3504 containers il fait
partie d'une nouvelle flotte de quatre
navires qui navigueront désormais entre
l'europe et les antilles et viendront
renforcer les capacités du port maritime
de fort de france
kimi dernier 13 non seulement bien
alimenter le marché un tiers est aussi
est un maître des affaires du
transbordement à fort de france et sur
les une sur les idées là-dessus at-elle
dit mais la taille ne peuvent pas
recevoir des navires de cette taille
stéphane carpentier le commandant du
navire
c'est notre guide à bord la visite
détaillée des buts par la salle des
machines
une équipe dirigée par une chef
mécanicien ici tout ou presque est
électronique
voilà c'est ça c'est surtout une
nouvelle génération de bateaux et une
nouvelle génération de moteurs c'est des
moteurs qui sont gérés de façon
électronique
donc ça permet de réduire la
consommation et voilà ça c'est vraiment
la vie la vraie nouvelle génération de
moteurs qu'on a sur ce bateau là haut
direction ensuite le centre névralgique
du navire ici la patronne c'est marie
elle est second capitaine et s'occupe
entre autres du chargement du helmand
donc nous avons un tonnage de 18 1794
tonnes en charge principalement ici des
riffs heures donc des conteneurs
réfrigérés pour amener des bananes le
bateau compte donc 12 niveaux jusqu'à la
passerelle supérieur et à chaque étage
ses particularités
ce navire est une ville flottante
autonome qui peut aussi accueillir des
passagers pour des transatlantiques
stéphane carpentier on a pris les
commandes il y a seulement deux mois les
premières choses qu'on va regarder c'est
les qualités manoeuvrière du navire en
fait à temps d'acclimatation au niveau
de l'oeil parce que chaque bateau est
différent en taille en largeur mais pas
forcément situé au même endroit sur tous
les navires je vous lis peu à peu près
je pense de voyage de quatre mois pour
commencer à prendre un petit peu la
dimension réelle du navire ce navire
porte le nom de fort de france
comme un clin d'oeil à la ville capitale
qui fête ses 350 ans il sera baptisé
demain en présence notamment de la
ministre de l'outre-mer